[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre cette
fille tu choisirais avait de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro le
sommaire de ce jeudi 28 mars avant de
devenir de vrais petits garçons les
marionnettes investissent la salle
d'exposition de l'hôtel de ville de la
celle-saint-cloud découverte de leur
histoire et de leur fabrication avec
deux passionnés de la figurine articulée
son nouveau directeur a pris ses
fonctions le 1er janvier dernier le parc
du château de dampierre s'ouvre de
nouveaux prêts publics
pascal thévard sera avec nous en plateau
les étudiants de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines relance le
festival un sens et une première édition
avait eu lieu en 2017 la deuxième sera
les 30 et 31 mars prochains sur le thème
de la diversité
elles ont enchanté votre enfance elles
ont parodié l'information durant 30 ans
les marionnettes marque les époques et
les esprits de passionnés exposé
collection et création à la celle saint
cloud nous sommes allés faire trois
petits tours nicolas et pimprenelle
souhaiter bonne nuit au petit pinocchio
voulait devenir un vrai petit garçon et
guignol fait toujours vivre les
spectacles pour enfants toutes ces
marionnettes se sont installés dans les
400 m² de salles d'exposition de l'hôtel
de ville de la celle-saint-cloud
première actes elle vous raconte leur
histoire
mon mari m'a finalement probablement a
vu naître un jour une caverne parce
qu'un petit enfant a pris un bâton et un
un petit caillou et qu'il les a mis en
rapport et qu'il a fait parler de sorte
qu'on peut dire que c'est le premier art
qui avait le jour bien avant la
sculpture bien avant le théâtre vient
d'avoir la peinture la marionnette a
ouvert la voie en particulier du courant
dramatique passionné de la marionnette
marc andrey est une véritable
encyclopédie de l'art du castelet de la
première la marionnettes à tringles à la
marionnette à gaine et l'exposent une
bonne partie de sa collection
lorsque le jeu est terminé on posa
marionnettes on en prend éventuellement
une autre elle fait toujours rentrer
cour jardin dans les mêmes conventions
que au théâtre deuxième acte l'époque
contemporaine et les différentes
techniques de fabrication du bois au
polystyrène nadine delannoy s'est formé
auprès des plus grands artisans pour
apprendre
tout leur secret est un hobby dont elle
fait son métier après un licenciement
économique
quand mes ex collègues m'ont vu
commencer à fabriquer des marionnettes
se sont dit c'est une lubie quinze ans
après vous voyez pas du tout ça occupe
l'intégralité de mes journées
aujourd'hui mon travail est reconnu
elle dédie l'exposition à vladimir
sakharov inventeur de la marionnette à
poigne et récemment décédé qui lui avait
enseigné toutes les précisions de son
travail de plasticienne elle a même cédé
à la tentation de marionnettistes et
fait vivre l'une de ses créations
madame lemieux sa fille je serais très
heureuse de vous rencontrer
la scène s'animent fois les 200
marionnettes sont présente jusqu'au 14
avril
nadine delannoy et marc-andré
partageront leur passion leur devise et
animer les dimanches 31 mars et le 14
avril date du 15ème siècle les xviie
siècle où la db roi louis xiv et louis
15e ces journées sont part que ces
jardins sont attribués à andré le nôtre
il était fermé au public depuis 2016 le
château de dampierre ouvre les portes de
son parc ce week-end pascal téva vous en
êtes le directeur général
bonjour bonsoir alors samedi c'est une
nouvelle saison et même une nouvelle vie
qui débute pour ce château et ce pour
tous surtout pour son parcours dans un
premier temps c'est un réveil pour
dampierre après quelques années fermée
au public et bien dans pierrot rouvre
les portes de son parc en effet puisque
les jardins seront accessibles à tous
les publics
et puis une partie de la forêt aussi en
visite en calèche et malheureusement le
château reste fermé parce que son état
nécessite des travaux et on pourra
ouvrir dans quelques années alors
l'identité de ce site historique c'est
aussi les carrosses quelques calèches et
on pourra les voir
et oui on pourra voir les carrosses le
familiaux de
la famille de luynes pardon c'est des
carrosses qui datent du 19e siècle qu'on
a retrouvés dans les remises et à
l'occasion de cette ouverture il nous
paraissait important de montrer ses
carrosses au public et ses calèches
notamment parce que le propriétaire du
château de dampierre est un fan de
déplacement hippomobile et qu'il a
lui-même un musée de carros il qui
nécessite la construction d'un bâtiment
pour l'accueillir prochainement à
dampierre met donc en prélude il ya six
véhicules qui sont exposées dans les
remises du 19e siècle du château
la promesse est donc une balade et des
activités alors il ya plusieurs
activités qui sont évidemment prévus sur
le domaine
il y à la balade en calèche à la balade
en calèche tirée par des mules
américaine permettra de découvrir au
rythme des animaux et bien le partage le
terrain sur les jardins dans le parc
forestier d'approcher des dindes
approcher les sangliers
et puis à côté de ça et bien d'autres
animations comme par exemple les
rosalies les golfs est mais aussi des
aires de jeux et des aires de pique
nique qui permet de compléter l'ensemble
pour passer une journée fort agréable à
dampierre il ya déjà des rendez-vous des
événements qui sont prévues oui
évidemment on a rythmé toute l'année une
fois par mois parler des animations des
animations qui sont souvent liées au
thème propre de dampierre par exemple le
6 avril prochain tout l'après midi c'est
des fanfares sonnée par les trompes du
château de dampierre qui viendront
évidemment inaugurer cette nouvelle
année au mois de mai c'est la
fauconnerie louis xiii
grand amateur de fauconnerie avec comme
gros fauconnier le duc de luynes de
l'époque comme adjoint c'est un rallye
automobile rallye caritatif qui passe de
versailles à marly en passant dans la
cour de dampierre au mois de juillet
c'est une démonstration de voitures
hippomobiles contemporaine mois
septembre évidemment c'est les journées
du patrimoine
et puis au mois d'octobre nous avons un
atelier photographique pour permettre à
tout public d'appréhender la photo et
d'appréhender les paysages les natures
la faune la flore autour du château
donc là la première étape c'est les
alentours du château d'eau de projets
pour ce site
si peu et d'autres projets pour ce site
puisque
nous allons profiter du passage du tour
de france le 28 juillet prochain pour
mettre à l'honneur jeu dampierre grâce à
l'intervention d'une artiste
plasticienne marie france sur hbo à la
toussaint pendant les vacances scolaires
des animations liées un thème de
l'automne sur les temps notamment
et puis à noël et bien des grandes
animations de noël
là aussi oublié sur les temps au tour de
l'étang et des mises en lumière un peu
féerique pour animer ce domaine le
château est toujours en innovation alors
le château n'est pas encore une ovation
l'architecte en chef des monuments
historiques christophe boutineau est en
train de mener toutes les études les
plus sérieuses puisque nous avons à
faire un patrimoine qu'on a amassé
monumentale et peut-être de nouveau
nommé nationale et donc du coup c'est
des études sérieuses qui permettent
d'identifier les problèmes de structure
les problèmes de restauration et de
conservation de se manie de ce bâtiment
donc les études sont en cours ça avance
bien le temps de les faire valider le
temps de faire les appels d'offres et
puis ensuite on rentre en période de
travaux pour le bientôt pourra mettre à
tout public de visiter donc première
étape les jardins à quelle heure on peut
venir samedi dès samedi ça ouvre à 10
heures et tous les jours de l'année ça
aura 10 heures jusqu'à 17h30 la
billetterie est ouverte et on reste dans
le jardin jusqu'à la tombée de la nuit
jusqu'à jester prend plus la demande est
envoyée prix merci pascal colas et
beaucoup de plateau avec le printemps
arrive les festivals une plongée dans la
culture de notre cote armorique avec le
fest-noz depuis plus de vingt ans le
cercle celtique 16 havel de trappes
organise son festival celtique concerts
initiations à la danse bretonne
exposition photos tout un programme ce
samedi 30 mars à la merise les amis de
l'examiner et de la culture de many
l'amant aussi ont une soirée sceptiques
à vous proposer ce samedi 30 mars à
l'estaminet café à partir de 20h et de
la cornemuse aux riffs de guitare amarré
sur mode ce sera plus rock'n'roll
six groupes investissent la salle des
fêtes vendredi et samedi à 20 heures et
à 19 heures un événement organisé par
l'association dynamite les étudiantes de
l'uv est ce qu ont lancé en 2010 est le
festival un sens c'est une découverte
sur deux jours de l'art et la culture
ils reviennent en 2019 pour une deuxième
édition sur le thème de la diversité
les 29 et 30 mars ils investissent la
batterie à guyancourt
l'espace extérieur du centre commercial
de saint quentin en yvelines et la
maison de l'étudiant marc tapant un mot
d'ordre local
l'objectif est de fédérer étudiants et
habitants autour d'artistes du bassin
saint quentinois la présidente du
festival était sur le plateau du 7-8
culture ce mardi 26 mars
il y aura différentes choses autant d
sert de tout au long de la journée du
samedi on aura du théâtre on aura des
ateliers participatifs de danse de hip
hop bachata danse égyptienne
on aura aussi du cirque en extérieur le
village associatif en lien avec anima
sauce plein de choses diverses je vous
laisse venir pour découverte dans le
cadre de sa saison jeune public l'espace
philippe noiret vous entraîne dans une
histoire d'aménagement pour enfants
c'est votre rubrique dans les salles de
patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
bonjour alors cette semaine à l'espace
philippe noiret je vous recommande pour
les plus jeunes spectateurs à partir de
2 ans et demi trois ans on va dire un
programme d'animation en stop motion
pathé mad des ménages donc voilà c'est
l'histoire de deux bricoleurs un peu
maladroit qui vont poser leurs cartons
dans une nouvelle maison et ils vont
trouver plein de solutions créatives
pour faire face aux petits défis de leur
quotidien
donc c'est une série qui nous vient de
république tchèque
en fait ça vient donc des années 80 il
ya une série qui est passé à la télé qui
a eu un grand succès et ils ont été
repris dans les années 2000 donc et
modernisé voilà là c'est un programme de
34 minutes donc c'est vraiment adapté
pour les plus jeunes spectateurs et il
ya 5 5 films d'animation avec pleins de
gags burlesques et très loufoque voilà
c'est pour les plus jeunes à l'espace
mort et cette semaine et je rappelle que
c'est dans le cas de notre saison jeune
public donc vous avez les dates bien en
avant si vous voulez réserver vos places
pour venir en famille
[Musique]
deux clubs saint quentinois s'affrontent
sur un terrain de football ce dimanche
31 mars
guyancourt reçoit plaisir au stade
maurice baquet les plus gros à qui
devront lutter pour leur survie en
première division de district quatre
courses et de nouveaux parcours c'est la
septième édition du bike and run de la
minière organisé par le triathlon club
saint quentin en yvelines départ ce
dimanche 31 mars à 9h pour des courses
ouvert dès l'âge de 8 ans et maintenant
je vous amène dans la ville de l'amour
pour un coup de foudre
[Musique]
un duo d'artistes qui veut provoquer en
vous des émotions intenses pour
l'exposition coup de foudre les trois
étages de la fondation edf sont
transformés en salle de bal vol bill ok
de nos confrères via grand paris qui a
enfilé son costume
c'est une exposition qui ne vous
laissera pas indifférent
coup de foudre s approprie jusqu'au 20
octobre prochain les trois étages de la
fondation edf
un rendez vous que le duo d'artistes
fabrice hyber nathalie talec a voulu
participatif des feutres pour dessiner
sur les murs aux costumes mise à
disposition des visiteurs pour enflammer
la salle de bal toute l'exposition a été
construite pour faire ressentir des
émotions aux visiteurs
l'idée c'était de de provoquer un espace
différent dans lesquels on met les
objets ou des oeuvres peuvent provoquer
des coups de feu
suggérer aux gens que tout est possible
que tout notre monde sont possibles donc
on leur donne on leur donne les outils
sur des habits des ustensiles et ils
pourront danser dans la formation adf
il y avait des amis surtout les amis ou
en famille ça pas mal ça permet aussi
d'avoir des moments un peu
un peu décalé drôle un peu festif un peu
des questions forcément puisque des
objets soit vous voyez pas ailleurs yves
ollivaud en profiter après un bal
revisiter un jeu de chassé croisé dans
l'obscurité au sous-sol place la
l'extase au premier étage un cadavre
exquis entre les deux artistes qui
recouvre toutes les parois de cette
mezzanine surplombant la piste de danse
coup de foudre offre un voyage
émotionnel réussi mise en place par un
duo qui signe là sa première
collaboration
je proposais à fabrice de m'accompagner
dans cette aventure et c'est ce qui nous
a conduit pour la première fois pour lui
comme pour moi a travaillé à 2
parce que je ne laisse jamais fait
auparavant fabrice non plus donc
certaine sympathie de défi artistique de
défi émotionnel
des vies sentimentales de d
tout coup de foudre il traversait des
émotions qui électrifie ras la fondation
aider jusqu'au 20 octobre prochain et
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 choisir
merci nous avoir suivis et rendez vous
la semaine prochaine à charbon soir sur
tv 78
[Musique]
oui
oh
[Musique]